president biden bailing on a huge speech
about inflation today as democrats beg
joe to take action vulnerable liberals
are reportedly worried the supply chain
crisis is going to bite them in next
year's midterms biden was supposed to
reassure americans after meeting with
top ceos about this issue earlier but he
abruptly scrapped those plans and
rescheduled the speech for wednesday
jesse
what does this mean is rescheduling my
sources not one day but for two days
what are your sources my sources are
saying hunter relapsed um
i don't have any sources i'm kidding i
don't have any sources you think i have
sources in the biden white house
um here's the thing with the supply
chain crisis i i'm surprised we still
have one didn't joe biden fix it when he
said he was going to keep the ports open
it is considered what happened to that
great fix two months ago he's just going
to keep him open 24 7 right so i looked
into this only one terminal in the two
largest ports in la and long beach
one terminal stayed up open overnight
for a few days no truckers came by not a
single trucker came by to pick up some
cargo so they go you know we're just
going to close it so what did joe do
did he solve the trucking issue no he
slapped vax mandates on truckers the
people that literally don't come close
to anyone in weeks so that's what he did
there the reason we have this also
besides moving the factories to china is
because fauci shut down this economy no
one's ever done that in the history of
the world shut down an economy because
of a pandemic why did he do it because
it mostly affects old people who run the
country old people old people don't want
to die they run things so they're like
all right no one get near me so no one
no one got near old people but then the
old people wouldn't let anybody else get
near themselves right so everybody
stayed home and so as we came back up
joe dropped two trillion in like i don't
know the same month as the economy
reopened that's like fiscal
methamphetamine got built
right to the moon and then we have this
inflation the economists are like oh my
god i didn't see this coming it's like
the only profession they get paid to not
see things coming you are always
unexpected when you're an economy
you're more entertaining than drunk
history
that sounded like drunk
actually buried within a lot of that was
the truth yeah right you were going to
take issue with something there were you
he said that the supply chain crisis is
better i i think supply chain is they
say it's eased by at least one-third and
by the count of the containers uh but we
don't do stories about
uh processes working we only do things i
couldn't find bananas at the grocery
store yesterday yeah bananas
you you didn't where were you in your
neighborhood bodega i don't i don't know
i don't go there
but let me say this about inflation yes
inflate debbie brooks was right in a
white-hot economy and we have a
white-hot economy now we have to face
facts that things are really buzzing
deagon can tell us even more
specifically with her great acumen and
in business but without sucking up
when when business is humming
you know you have you oh you do have
some supply issues price goes up
people are getting more and more jobs
they're
you know for higher signs still
everywhere there are more people being
hired the workforce is expanding we have
i think a reasonable expectation in the
first quarter of next year we're going
to have a functional
prosperous country if it is not derailed
by covid i keep coming back to it all of
these stories about everything else mean
nothing if the nation gets sick again
and gets scared again and gets
cloistered again and old people get
isolated again
dagon care to respond he after he
buttered you up like a
butterball turkey the economy is not hot
for a lot of people wages adjusting for
inflation or real wages are down more
than two percent since january of this
year so inflation is for the upper class
is an inconvenience but for working men
and women in this country it is a great
hardship and that is something and i
don't want to step on what dana's going
to talk about but that is something from
moment one the the biden administration
joe biden himself
never got their heads around they were
slow to acknowledge it they said it's
transitory the federal reserve just
keeps pumping juice into the economy you
got ron klein retweeting that it's a
high class problem
total insensitivity
to people who have to choose between
okay what am i eating for dinner and
can i fill up my car tomorrow morning
and it's just so of course joe biden's
not gonna talk today he's like you can
see it oh my god i gotta go out there
and act like i care i gotta i i gotta
like
they do they do not care and they ca and
jo jin soccer today
today kept keeps saying that build back
better this giant welfare monstrosity is
going to help inflation see again those
egghead economists are stupid they
didn't see this coming the fed the
inflation rate is three times what they
expected it would be and jinsaki is
standing up there telling the american
people what they know is not true all
right dana well i think part of the
thing is that they initially said that
inflation wasn't happening then i said
it would be temporary and then they said
well it's really not that bad it's like
your turkey's only a dollar more right
uh or it's a high class problem but then
they realize oh wait the poll numbers
are actually showing up something bad so
then they started to blame everyone but
the problem is they're not on the same
page in terms of who they're blaming for
example they
they are blaming energy companies for
rising gas prices while at the same time
talking to opec begging them to increase
production so it's like one bad thing
after another there you go one bad thing
after another one comment in
administration how how how can you
condemn buildback better at the same
time you bemoan
the situation with the lowest uh paid
people the most humble amongst us
because it's inflation that's eating
another wages what you make is an
argument for build back benefits
you were it's not because it's a welfare
monstrosity and it pumps more money it
pumps more money into economy that
doesn't need more that does not need
more fiscal stimulus yeah money that
does that the economy doesn't mean
number one you know what your evidence
of what what democrats think about doing
nothing it's enough
get the hell out of the way that's what
you ought to do in this economy hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else